hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 9 video
we have one more week before the
mid-season break so I'll explain what
the schedules gonna be with agent Carter
and when shield is coming back they
totally dropped a terrigen bomb reveal
in the episode I think it was something
that we had suspected all along but I'll
explain how I think that's gonna work
with the cinematic universe so careful
for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen it yet but starting with
top five moments number five the Patton
Oswalt wins
technically it's triplets because
remember one of them died weren't killed
one of them which they happily let him
know when he came on board the bus
there's this really funny thing Patton
Oswalt said one time he's been working
at Hollywood for a long time as a script
writer or he doesn't really write script
so much as he helps fix them even I
think as far back as maybe like the late
90s they would call him in for big
animated movies and he would do
something called punch up where he would
take a script or a movie that they had
finished and make it funnier by
inserting like little jokes like
characters off screen that would say
things just to make scenes funnier and
that's really what he was used for in
this episode he got some really cool
moments but generally he was like the
person that brought all the jokes into
the episode technically he was not punch
up for this episode like he was written
in at the script stage like they didn't
bring him in after they'd finished it
but I feel like if we hadn't seen Patton
Oswalt choking up this episode it would
have gone completely flat like you have
to have the funny moments in order for
the really scary moments to land it's
not so much an easter egg either but
that umbrella was like that very penguin
looking umbrella was a nice callback to
Patton Oswalt at one point being rumored
to play the penguin in the Batman
franchise Patton Oswalt would make a
perfect penguin but that's the DC
Universe he's in the Marvel Universe now
so we might not never see that come to
play but I felt like that was a nice
shout out for that especially if you
were around whenever those rumors were
going on I think that was in the early
days of the Christopher Nolan Dark
Knight trilogy when that was rumored or
maybe even before that there was
actually a point when Patton Oswalt was
first cast on agents of shield last year
when he thought that they were casting
him as MODOK
it was just something funny that he said
just based on the way he looked like he
doesn't look like your typical badass
SHIELD agent so he was like am i MODOK
is that is that what they're casting me
as just some great inside jokes he's
just so good at deflating tension
especially when he has invisibility
umbrellas number four
mockingbirds teases a secret team and a
possible secret Nick Fury plan if he
caught that moment in the cockpit where
she said she didn't want to bring hunter
in on the other thing that other thing
is possibly a side Nick Fury plot she
was dancing around it but it seems like
she does not want Coulson to destroy the
city I don't think that makes her evil
like she's not a double agent but she
could be doing something for Nick Fury
at this point I do feel like the city is
Attilan I feel like that's confirmed
I'll explain that in a second but if you
remember in the original Avengers movie
he talks about the Phase two weapons the
tesseract based energy weapons I think
the city and the Inhumans are gonna turn
into the Phase three weapons type thing
or at least that might be the idea that
Fury has I don't think it's gonna go
down exactly the way they plan it but it
seems like Mockingbird might turn on
Coulson when he tries to blow the city I
do think that they'll have that big WTF
moment where he has his hand on a button
and gets ready to blow it up and someone
jumps to try and stop him it just feels
like a very TV moment so I of course I
think they're gonna do it there's no way
that Kevin Feige would let them destroy
the city of the Inhumans on TV without
it ever appearing in the movies that's
one of the first problems of having a
shared Cinematic Universe that's planned
out far in advance it has a way of
circumventing a lot of the tension that
you try to create in television based
stories raising the WTF just a couple
steps number three agent 33 still has
like a really messed-up version of May's
face just explain her face is stuck like
that the reason that big scar shows is
because underneath that her face is
really messed up and the disguising
technology is totally messed up like
it's fused with her so she's stuck like
that me not posted a picture of this
last week with her with a messed up face
makeup on I was actually pretty shocked
because it implied that something really
crazy was gonna happen to me but then
when I saw was agent 33 you know was all
explained somehow I do not feel like
they're gonna be able to redeem her like
she's gonna have to die although you get
the sense that she is going to turn on
Whitehall like she's conflicted I think
they'll be able to break her programming
but she'll still have to die the only
other option for her is to become one of
these new Inhumans and I don't feel like
she's on that path I kept waiting for
the entire episode for me to address
that though do you realize she's still
wearing my face who knew May was so vain
it is really creepy though but it was
nice that they totally gave that Patton
Oswalt joke like right after that to
completely deflate the moment it was
just a very
joke number two team Colson finds the
entrance to the city but it completely
messes Mac up here's what I think is
going down I think that's an automated
defense mechanism of the city that it
turns invaders against themselves it
could mean that Mac has inhuman
potential in him otherwise you know I
might have just turned him to stone or
dust like it does everyone else I would
totally love to see like a Mac inhuman
just him all holdout without actually
being the Hulk and yes you know I mean
he fell down the shaft but there's no
way that he's completely dead like
whatever the changes happened to him
they clearly made him almost invincible
so he was totally gonna come back in the
next episode I just I don't think
they're gonna make it into the city
until either rain or earth sky touches
the obelisk - that symbol on the floor
speaking of which number one WTF moment
of course Rana explains the Kree this
was like a really huge moment I feel
like it just did not land the way they
intended it though because we've been
saying Kree all season long I think even
since last season there were a couple
possibilities for the blue Alien and
Tahiti but really after the first
episode and after they did the big
guardians of the galaxy storyline cream
straight-up Kree the real story now
though is Inhumans they haven't
officially confirmed it like they
haven't set it out out loud on the show
but if you look at this cover of the
Inhumans comic that they just released
or they're getting ready to release the
symbols near black bolts throne same
symbols as the one of the map of the
city Coulson has so yeah of course
Inhumans totally like I said just a
second ago one of the big problems of a
highly pre-planned
Cinematic Universe is that you see
things coming a mile away if you're one
of those people that reads the comics
this is where DC has an advantage and
that the TV shows the DC TV shows like
arrow and the flash can do whatever they
want regardless of what the movies want
so there's still some surprises they can
throw at you it is a matter of opinion
which you think is better because you
know sometimes it is fun when you know
that they're gonna do something really
big that you enjoyed the downside being
that you don't get the big WTF reveal
that you would have gotten if you didn't
know it was coming and now the
conversation turns to our Skye and Raina
gonna turn into people from the comics
in last week's video I explained how I
think Skye is gonna get like the
earth-based power she's gonna be able to
cause quakes I don't think they're gonna
change her face I think she'll still be
like Chloe Bennet looking they might
give her glowy eyes or something like
that but
they're not gonna give her giant
prosthetics or anything Reena on the
other hand I think it's gonna have more
emotion or psychic based powers that
just lends itself to some of the aspects
that her character has already if they
don't kill her off I really hope they do
not kill her off if anyone is gonna turn
into an actual monster I think it's
gonna be Skye's father he's already got
the dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde thing going on I
think I also addressed that in last
week's video so I mean I'll have links
to that at the end of this let me know
though what was your favorite moment
from the episode and which Inhumans do
you want to see Skye and Raina turn into
the only real big Easter Egg I saw in
the episode and I'm not considering the
Korean Easter Egg because it was at the
Easter Egg level when we first saw that
blue alien but it was the Bermuda
Triangle shoutout Clark Drake says they
figured it out in 80s in 1980 they
actually had a storyline called Hulk
island where there was an island that
the Hulk went to in the Bermuda Triangle
overall I had to give the episode of B I
mean it was a complete set up for the
finale so there wasn't a lot of dramatic
tension and we saw the big reveal the
Kree reveal coming miles and miles away
that being said best performance in the
episode totally Patton Oswalt if you
can't give them a scare then give them a
laugh and that's what he does best
so obviously whenever he shows up in an
episode he's gonna do something
hilarious I felt like it was just a
bonus that they gave him like the action
comedy moment like this could have been
a Schwarzenegger movie from the 80s like
the way they took down some of those
Hydra people I will give the show the
benefit of the doubt so next week when
we have the big mid-season finale you
know what they become we find out what
they actually become I will give them a
giant high-five if they have the balls
to like physically alter one of their
main cast members permanently for the
show that's just like a lot of work
every week for them to show that
character I will give them props I still
feel like there's absolutely no way
we're gonna see the royal family they
might tease them or there might be some
Easter eggs but I still feel like those
characters are gonna premiere in the
movies so right now big announcements
here are the really important dates
about windshields coming back when agent
Carter's happening next week she'll goes
on break episode 11 whatever comes back
will be March 3rd agent Carter's gonna
premiere January 6th and it'll run for 8
episodes no idea what their big
overarching storyline is but it'll
probably tie in with the film's like
it'll be integrated into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in a small way we're
totally gonna see Howard Stark they cast
the real-life Jarvis so it's gonna be
awesome totally
check it out I will be doing weekly
videos for it so be sure to subscribe to
get all that stuff if you're not in
terms of the crossover with Avengers 2
yes there will be characters from agents
of shield featured like they'll get
small cameos right now triplet is the
only person that we know of for sure
probably Coulson - he might just get
referenced though Clark Craig has said
he's not in it but I've heard rumors
that he is so we'll see of all the other
characters Mockingbird is the other one
that has potential to show up in the
film's they are doing Avengers 2
reshoots right now so if there's any big
information that comes out of that like
if they add any scenes or any characters
especially agents of shield characters
I'll be sure to do a bonus video for it
so if you're watching this on your
mobile phone or your tablet I have new
mobile links up here it's the same as
the links that I had over here but click
here for my episode 8 video I talked a
little bit about who I think this guy is
gonna turn into and click here to learn
all about Daniel Bruhl in Captain
America 3 and who he might be plank
which villain you might be playing thank
you so much for watching so that's all
high five I will see you guys tonight
you